well let's get the very latest for you
on the situation in the east of ukraine
i'm joined now by ed arnold ed is a
research fellow at the royal united
services institute or rusi as some of us
know ed good to have you back on the
program so well over 100 days into this
brutal war now what is the situation on
the ground in the east which is the area
we can see here can't we in the red and
white stripes
so russians and the east are starting to
make steady progress and it's really
centered around the city of several
donetsk advances using heavy use of
artillery
in order to try and take that city and
also russian forces stepping up their
propaganda campaign against ukrainian
troops ukrainian troops in the area
starting to receive text messages
designed to lower ukrainian morale which
must be starting to lower for the first
time in this war uh ukraine has gone
public with its casualty figures and
it's assessed with a range of about 100
250 killed in action a day and between
500 and 800
wounded in action also per day
that's unsustainable at the moment and
while ukraine have been very successful
at mobilizing they've roughly doubled
their available um
[Music]
forces uh since the start of the war
these are relatively inexperienced uh
potential troops and on the east they
made the decision at the start of the
war to put their most experienced troops
on the contact line in the donbass so
this is a real critical time for ukraine
at the moment yeah it sounds absolutely
brutal doesn't it on the ground of
course we have president zielenski
talking last night saying the fate of
seven donets is going to determine the
fate of the whole of this region i mean
do you agree with that on a military
point of view not quite from a military
point of view but potentially uh
politically so the
soviet united is very important but
ukraine are actually choosing to fight
forward at the moment so they're
actually trying to fight and draw russia
in uh russian forces in to fight hand to
hand and then really within the city
themselves um they don't have to they
could have withdrawn um
west to la chance which is actually
defensively a better area and also it
means that you have the swerzki donetsk
river that actually is a very it's a
natural uh defensive location which the
ukrainians would be able to use but what
ukraine is trying to do is delay the
russian advance because they need time
they need time to get uh western heavier
weapons up there
earlier this week didn't we these
long-range missile systems exactly
artillery rockets they've got a longer
range in the russian systems they're
more mobile and also they're more
accurate so in order to do a proper
counter offensive from a ukrainian point
of view and start to try and win back
some of this territory they really need
that heavier not just firepower but they
also need maneuver capabilities for
tanks as well so they're trying to buy
time to be able to bring that forward
and then get it
into the battle which will be very
effective when they were able to do so
okay let's get your views on some
reports coming out as well from the uk
ministry of defence saying that russia
is on maneuvers elsewhere in the east of
this area so what do you think is going
on here
so in terms of issues so the the main
axis in mid-april when phase two of this
war started and russia wanted to focus
in the east and the south it was all
centered on issues it's so important
that reportedly the chief of the general
staff was personally taking command of
that operation but after about four
weeks that really stalled what's
happening now is they're starting to get
tempo momentum back into their
operations and they're starting to be
able to move
uh southeast
and why is this important well if they
continue that momentum and they're able
to resource it at the same time that
they can put pressure on several donets
they can start to move on slovenians to
the north which was a ukrainian position
quite difficult and they're going to
have to start to move back to try and
protect soviet lands to keep the donbass
contested at the moment
the mood seems to have changed somewhat
doesn't it it seems to be certainly more
downbeat when looking at ukrainian
progress would you agree with that yeah
i mean this is very heavy fighting and
the fact that the ukrainian forces have
managed to hold out as long as they had
and
really blunt russian offensives in a
number of areas is really important and
they do want to counter-attack and
counter-attacking is more of a mindset
they really want to do it they just
don't currently have the capabilities in
the right place if they're able to bring
more forces forward fresher troops and
also get these capabilities
from the west get trained on them and
then be able to bring them to bear in
this area then the momentum might switch
back to ukraine's way okay ed for now
thank you very much plenty more from ed
arnold throughout the course of our time
here on skype